- I'm so glad you guys
could make it to this week's
book club.
The book for today's meeting
is the card game, euchre.
- Ooh-cre. Ooh-cre.
- I've never played euchre,
so you guys are gonna have
to be patient with me.
- We play a very special
six man derivation of euchre
played in the hills
of northern England.
- Yeah, basically
we trimmed the fat.
We got rid of every crad
except for the benny.
The Bowers all left right
and back shoot in left queen.
- And never lead with a benny.
- Unless you're a defender
and you didn't call trump.
- Then you can inspect the
kitty whenever you want.
- But if you get caught,
no left bowers.
- And you cannot cut
thick to win unless
you're thick with bennys
and the kitty is clean.
- You can never
euchre alone though.
- Well you can if
you stick the dick.
- If the dick
skee-do-ricks, the gas pass.
- No face, no ace, no trump
dump or commie bean gorillas
in the sixth inspection can
beat the fishing out a dutchman.
- Stick the dick, stick
the dick, stick the dick.
- You go first,
- Hmm.
- Wrong, negative 20.
- You're not gonna
have enough points.
- Go in the kitchen.
- Go to the kitchen!
Euchre.
- Ookre, ookre, rookre,
- Ooh.
Ooh.
- Ooh. Good. Ker.
Euchre.
- Ookre.
(classical music)